muito boa tarde a todos
eu sou o carlos neto professor da
faculdade de estado mandou lançado em
lisboa do comportamento esportista uso
do laboratório de comportamento do ator
e como foi deitar mais 40 anos que venho
investigando estã o desenvolvimento
motor e o jô das crianças e jovens e
verifica se de facto há um declínio uma
decadência progressiva do brincar e ser
ativo nem fácil
é de facto nós podemos afirmar pelos
dados que dispomos que as crianças
brincam - demora por dia
os prisioneiros das prisões têm mais
tempo livre de ócio fora da cela do que
as crianças no seu cotidiano
é uma coisa absolutamente lamentável e é
obviamente que também se verifica uma
progressiva é tendência para as doenças
cardio respiratórias e cardíacas e
pulmonares
assim como as crianças apresentam um
terço já o chef peso e é aberta está
facto é possivelmente a aumentar
diríamos também que se verifica uma
diminuição de competências motoras e
conquistas sociais e também ao mesmo
tempo podemos constatar que se verifica
no domínio das crianças e jovens um
problema nacional
com a diminuição do tempo passado no
exterior e também uma mesa de sinuca
esclarece que era o único local possível
das crianças ainda tenham tempo para
brincar forma livre
por outro lado temos as cargas horárias
maiores da assembléia e e every fica
obviamente também que as crianças têm
problemas muito sérios de liberdade e de
autonomia é de facto o que se passa hoje
em dia é que as nossas crianças estão a
ser trabalhadas
exatamente relacionadas vivem em
cativeiro não tem tempo nem espaço para
terem liberdade para terem autonomia
temos aqui uma situação inacreditável de
diminuição do tempo e espaço para que
possam brincar livremente
costumo dizer que as crianças saudáveis
são aquelas três grandes lagos
hoje temos as crianças e os jovens todos
limpos e isso é mau
significa que significa esta que estavam
sempre perguntar onde estão as crianças
onde andam as crianças
muito francamente eu não posso olhar
para a cidade e dizer que passei mais as
crianças à tona
isto é é considerar que é facto existe
uma situação do limite em que o corpo
vive uma forma inativa e não tem facto
condições para brincar forma livre em
julho de 2015
acho a explicação pública e esta
entrevista no jornal online e foi viral
em que afirmam que estávamos a criar
crenças total e na maturidade nem
acreditava facto nós necessitamos não
libertar as crianças e desejar mais
risco mais autonomia e mais participação
é esta é uma ideia que de algo mal
mostra que de facto
vivemos uma situação de grande
sedentarismo e analfabetismo tornam elas
provam que em pleno século 21
estivéssemos a falar desta necessidade
das crianças poderão brincar porque é um
comportamento natural é um comportamento
portanto é astral e isso significa que
hoje o sedentarismo eo estresse são duas
doenças
o facto do nosso tempo que vão criar
grande problema de saúde pública é curto
a médio e longo prazo o que significa
que hoje nós temos crianças com certo
analfabetismo por crianças que não sabem
que ressaltar não sabem equilibradas não
sabem
elas atrapalham a zaga do macaé não
deixe que eu sei que vivemos uma
situação paradoxal é e portanto esta
questão leva é que o seu reportório
motorista é muito impulsivo e crimes
gravíssimos problemas do ponto de vista
deverão ser o futuro sapatos expostos e
biográficos que todas as crianças
brincaram muito na infância está em
grande sucesso no futuro
isso acontece com os artistas acontece
que os desportistas e acontece
obviamente com tantos artistas ou
desportistas e os cientistas não
significa colocar ênfase é um
instrumento poderoso é um instrumento é
fundamental para se ter sucesso na vida
adulta e e estava na falta de motor tem
vindo a provocar vários problemas também
relacionados com o foro psicológico ea
capacidade de adaptação portanto uma
escola e ao sucesso escolar
não gosto do centro que fizemos
verificamos que o índice de mobilidade
autonomia globalidade das crianças no em
portugal era muito baixo
entre as espécies das notificações
ficamos em décimo quarto lugar o lado e
thales aa em israel e devemos verificar
que as crenças do norte europa tem muito
mais autonomia muito mais liberdade
são crianças mais salvagem são crianças
que factos vive mais no exterior do que
as crianças no sul da europa separarem
são essencialmente page do sul que têm
mais limitações e mais constrangimentos
neste nível de autonomia vai ficar nessa
compreensão que as crianças a norte da
europa
por volta dos 60 anos da rua paschoal a
andar de bicicleta na rua atravessam
estradas é sair pois cruzeiro andam
transportes públicos vão a outros locais
que não escola atravessam as ruas e
significa que em portugal e só se passa
por volta dos 3 14 anos
quer dizer que há aqui um conjunto de
constrangimentos que merecem ser
pensados e recebidos porque isso não
está a acontecer no nosso país
é nosso dever e brincar e ser ativo
desenvolvimento das capacidades é um
instrumento poderoso é é é facto algum
elemento essencial do próprio remédio
porque permite o desenvolvimento de uma
grande caçada sativa do ponto de vista
motor que pode estar social da conquista
do sinal do ponto de vista cognitivo
por outro lado é uma cultura de
sobrevivência porque que não brinca não
prendam não integra não assimila
questões fundamentais relacionadas com a
capacidade de ultrapassar problemas e
adversidades ver facto é a praça é
também portanto uma forma de regulação
emocional ao brincar eu estou a
reencontrar a importância do meu corpo
os objetos e o mundo que nos rodeia e
também o rendimento aumentar meu nível
da autoconfiança e autoestima e também o
grau de evolução social com os outros
brincar é portanto um instrumento
essencial em todas as espécies animais
principalmente homens por permite
desenvolver competências cognitivas e
conter assim todas que são
importantíssimos para a nossa
sobrevivência é de resto brincar é um
complemento astral pode ser observado em
todos os animais
nós temos em princípio uma infância
muito longa nós andamos em média 25 e 30
anos sem fazer nada quero dizer que a
corrupção se completem positivos depois
quando chega o fim da inocência
princípio sagrado adulta entrasse mas
ainda faz mais estúpidas a vida
trabalhando tem filhos é tetra e por
faltas novamente na fase da terceira
idade é ter mais algum descanso e uma
certa é compatibilidade entre o que é
filosofia de vida na infância e acontece
à candidata e ao dizer que brincaram com
o pensamento ancestral porque é uma
forma de se valorizar o corpo
brincar é atingir o limite o
imprevisível a capacidade de confrontar
se com 1.001 previsto incerto
é uma forma também de descobrir a
animalidade que está dentro de nós ea
forma como somos capazes de facto de
conseguir ser perseguidos pelo tar estas
três componentes fazem para todas as
pessoas animais e tentem fazer mais
longe a chance de brincar mais tempo
o que significa que se usar o corpo
significa que nas brincadeiras mais
triviais que as crianças fazem no
recreio como toque forte os polícias e
ladrões aquelas brincadeiras que nós
fazemos a nossa infância e que o apelo
às nossas memórias para crianças correm
são fundamentais porque matar o outro é
uma forma de simbolizar o corpo matar o
outro simbolicamente é uma forma de eu
criar cidadania e por isso não se podem
imprimir proibir eliminar essas
brincadeiras na infância
elas são os elementos fundamentais
significa portanto que é os brinquedos
bélicos também são essenciais no nosso
desenvolvimento presentes brincar e ser
ativo em fazer brincar correr riscos
o risco é um valor fundamental risco
significa autonomia significa também ter
mais confiança e ter mais segurança a
quem não é quem não tem risco não vai
dar segurança a quem não não tem risco
não permite que ter mais atenção é
fundamental para poder controlar se
soprasse significa que há uma relação
entre risco e segurança quem as crenças
que menos risco têm mais propensão tempo
o acidente
significa isto que todos os animais
incluídos seja modificar física na
infância por fé explicou que muitas vez
é pelo erro que nós aprendemos e o corpo
e se não existe na sua própria história
jiló genética significa que é preciso
que hoje se vá à escola os pais percebam
que os seus filhos
os alunos incitam o programa diferente e
por isso é necessário combater esta
história controla as energias
as crianças precisam de despender
energia significa que as crianças são
impertinentes as crianças necessitam de
facto de dispender essa energia e faz
parte da sua própria lógica interna ao
longo do ciclo vida humana é idade 56 78
anos é o momento nós temos mais
necessidade de despender energia e hoje
nós já temos com essas energias
completamente controladas faz aliás uma
grande confusão em tecnologias naturais
energia e patológicas
acreditações modificadas é um prazer
essa se mundial
não é porque de facto é nestas cidades o
empreendimento essencial que as crianças
possam dispender essa energia para
discutir de uma forma saudável é isso
significa que tem de ter uma mensagem
urgente para pais para indicadores nos
sentidos e não não terem a ideia que
crianças com este dirigia são
imperativas ou que necessitam de estar
quieta sentadas e esta é a praga do
século xxi para outra não significa que
hoje vivemos uma verdadeira patologia é
do país dos adultos no que diz respeito
às culturas do mesmo né
vivemos numa sociedade mesmo que esses
não têm liberdade não tá então
aprisionados vivem em cativeiro vivem em
cativeiro exames libertado por isso o
tema liberta das crianças é esta cultura
medo mesmo
verifica se basicamente tem múltiplo
nosso dia-a-dia imaginem aqui é o pai
que está à frente não escorregue criança
o seu filho com carew time completamente
significa que pais e seguros transmitir
segurança aos seus palpites
nós precisamos falar do facto de os mais
corajosos no sentido de compreender que
tem que se libertar destas construções
que foram feitas ao longo dos anos é do
mesmo das crianças poderão cair nas
crianças o interesse 27 as crianças têm
uma grande capacidade de auto-regulação
grande que precisa lidar com o risco uma
grande capacidade de reconhecimento de
si próprias e por isso combater as
culturas do mesmo é uma das prioridades
do nosso século
nós temos também os 200 que brincar e
ser ativo na infância é e principalmente
do reino e sal a desenvolvem o cérebro e
aumenta o sucesso claro quem brinca no
recreio forma mais ativa e têm mais
sinalização tem mais que precisava de
concentração e mais capacidade
de apreensão dos conhecimentos além do
pessoal da onu e por isso nós precisamos
mudar o facto esta situação também de
contato com a natureza abas conexão
completa entre a natureza ea criança é
fato as coisas vêm quatro pretos
em princípio o que se passa é que nós
matriculamos o corpo na escola para
fusão mas o corpo na cadeira e estamos
perante uma situação em que as crianças
têm que estar quietas e tem que estar
sentadas ouvir os estouros cansados os
olhos de choque
estamos passando necessidade é também um
problema sério
vivemos em um tempo dramático nesta
matéria de olhar pro corpo cortar
esquecido na escola e por isso
necessitamos de contratar mais a
natureza porque essa educação e essa
conexão com o mundo natural é
fundamental próprios envolvimento da mãe
não podemos viver separados da do
universo no sentido de conhecer as
propriedades do corpo e as propriedades
da natureza necessitam facto de brincar
no exterior e por isso é nós
necessitamos de brincar tratos na
infância porque isso é o melhor caminho
pra ser feliz
o empreendedor e ter sucesso na idade
adulta
quem brinca minha infância têm futuro
garantido
quem brinca muito na infância facto
viveu experiências muitas vezes são
experiências que ultrapassaram é que o
que estava legalmente instituídos
quem não se lembra que as melhores
memórias que têm são as coisas que foram
proibidas e que fizemos com muita
satisfação e com muito orgulho e hoje
basicamente tem se aquela ideia de que
por um lado e se pretende que os filhos
sejam gênios que as crianças tenham os
melhores notas notas no ranking e ao
mesmo tempo agora pela mão e
completamente essas perspectivas
isto é uma contradição profunda em todo
o sistema está em causa o futuro da
humanidade
se não fizermos uma inversão sobre esta
nova pensar este mote serviço móvel
isso significa portanto que nós temos
esta necessidade
atualmente a falar sobre o conceito vão
libertar as crianças de deixar que elas
vivam prisioneiros em tempo e espaço que
vivam amarradas facto em espaço interior
e por isso é preciso dizer que orientar
as crianças significa o livro talvez
esperem sentados e quietas de ter
precisado brincar livremente em casa na
rua na escola complementar em extinção
quem não brincava na rua onde aprenderam
coisas essenciais no desenvolvimento
por outro lado corre mais riscos
quanto mais risco mais superação quanto
mais pressão mas que precisa processo e
também acabar com esta história da
superlotação patológica a partir da
cultura do medo e da iliteracia motora e
love que as crianças
hoje nós vemos um grau de atividade
física como nunca existiu na história
o corpo tem limites o corpo necessita de
facto de poder usufruir do espaço
exterior poder correr poder ter condição
de tratar da sua saúde física e mental
ser bem estar
significa que esse combate à iliteracia
pintura analfabetismo touro é uma das
prioridades do nosso século
nós nos sempre botar sentados nós
nascemos pra correr
nós não temos ter apenas o mundo na
ponta dos dedos
as crianças passam em média duas horas e
meia por dia em frente à televisão foi
para a frente do computador para todos
os presentes tecnológicos o que
significa que vivem o corpo na ponta dos
dedos
é preciso inverter essa ideia nós temos
péssimos pensa em uma missão e essa
missão é facto de um carro ganhar
autonomia afastar-se dos países mas não
são donos dos filhos nem o seu som dos
alunos
significa também que temos que acabar
com essa ideia e agendas muito
estruturadas crianças da agenda entre o
tempo todo a organizar todas sinalizadas
todo estruturava todos formatava o corpo
está formatado completamente os dias 2 e
pronto a uma falta profunda participação
seja não tem participação
o mundo da escola por exemplo é o mundo
que está ultrapassado há mais de 150
anos
continuamos com o mesmo deu
perfeitamente loco o fundamento
ultrapassar a escola tem que mudar
e obviamente que é necessário ter mais
mobilidade e mais autonomia
nós ainda estamos vendo alguns vestígios
de crianças felizes uma espécie de
arqueologia lúdica nas nossas cidades
das nossas habitações na nossa escola
nós necessitamos de ter cidades amigas
das crianças
necessitamos urgentemente porque vai
colocar as crianças mais próximo da
natureza a fazer descobertas ventura
risco e jô
ser feliz é ser empreendedor ter sucesso
na vida adulta dependa de brincar muito
em fazer também
[Aplausos]